brett hume is a fox news senior
political analyst in fact he's i think
the only one
we're happy to have him joining us
tonight brit this is making me cynical i
thought when that january 6th thing
happened it was bad i hate it when
people break stuff you shouldn't
riot at a federal building period but
the disparity in the way that those
rioters were treated as compared to the
way the writers last summer were treated
is just too much and it's making me
feel like equal application of the law
is dead
if this recovered tucker the way the
riots of last summer were covered
it would be described as mostly peaceful
and i think
to a great extent it was peaceful the
picture that you've shown of the people
who were in the capitol building milling
around the guy walking around the senate
chamber with horns on and so on
most of them were peaceful but some
obviously were not right and that
explains the
the nightmare experience that the
undermanned and overwhelmed capitol
police officers who testified today had
to go through
some of they obviously had a terrible
experience and considered it a near
thing
but but there's certainly a disparity
between the way that this event was
covered in the way it's been responded
to politically
uh and the way that the more serious
rioting of last summer with more deaths
to show for it
have been treated 70 people were shot in
chicago this weekend which is to say two
days ago 70 people
i i wonder if adam kinser will cry about
that or maybe not because it's not about
him i mean i i wonder if there's ever
been a greater display of narcissism on
capitol hill and that's saying a lot but
like ever in history
i have noticed in the reactions of some
members of congress and some former
members of congress whom i've spoken to
about this these events
a very intense personal reaction
they are the ones who are inclined to
consider that this this
incident this riot and it was an ugly
riot to be sure and disturbing
um but they considered it had been an
insurrection it was an insurrection that
failed pretty spectacularly if that's
what it was when you consider
that the event that they were trying to
trying to interfere with which was the
formal counting of the votes for
president went off later that day
it was delayed but that was all they did
that doesn't strike me as very close to
overthrowing the government which is
what a lot of people claim that these
writers and insurrectionists
tried to do does it surprise you that
the capitol hill
police apparently the personal
bodyguards of the united states congress
has a budget that's more than twice that
of the entire
city of atlanta and about a hundred
million dollars more for the than the
entire city of detroit
one of the most dangerous places in the
western hemisphere like what is that
i gotta say to you tucker that i grew up
in washington and lived there most of my
life
and it is the most police city in the
united states
with more different police forces active
i mean you have the you have the u.s you
have the dc
police you have the capital police and
that's a very large force when it's
deployed in you know
with everybody and everybody out you got
the park police which is no small force
either you got the fbi you got the
uniformed services
division of the secret service you got
the aqueduct police i mean you got the
u.s mint police it goes
on and on and on and the total budget
for it
has got to be absolutely staggering no
it doesn't quite surprise me that the
capitol police budget would be so large
what's surprising
is that so few of them were there ready
and fully prepared to meet the onslaught
that came in the aftermath of the
of the trump rally when those people
went streaming down to capitol hill
and there's a lot to be investigated
here tucker about you know just why it
was that they were so
unprepared and under undermanned
underarmed and so forth to deal with
that
um because had they been properly
deployed i think
we could all agree that these people
would not have gotten into the capital
and what happened would not have
happened
not a single member of congress was
injured hundreds and hun more than a
thousand americans have died of murder
since then maybe they should spend more
time
worrying about the rest of the country
that's my personal view you don't have
to endorse that
but i appreciate your analysis brit hume
thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else